معنى في الاستوديو عثمان بوانين رئيسه
تحالف في قوى الخلاصه الوطنيه السوداني
مرحبا بكم معنا استاذ عثمان في العربيه
وفدان عن الجيش والدعم السريع الى جده في
السعوديه ولكن
للمفاوضات ولكن بشكل غير مباشر ما المامول
من مفاوضات جده هي بالحقيقه يعني في
المقام الاول هذه خطوه ايجابيه ترمي الى
الطريق الصحيح ولكن هي يعني نتمنى انه ان
تؤدي الى وقف اطلاق النار وفتح المسارات
للخدمات الانسانيه والى التحرك المواطنين
بامن وامان وايضا ارتدي الى الخطوه الاخرى
تاتي الى يعني سحب المقاتلين خارج المدن
والاحياء السكنيه الى خارج المعسكرات
استاذ
عثمان خليه كما تبعنا في خبر ورد قبل قليل
اتصال هاتفي من وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بنظيره السعودي لبحث الوضع في السودان
طبعا هذا يتوائم مع المبادرات وقف اطلاق
النار التي كانت مبادرات سعوديه امريكيه
كذلك انتم في قوى الخلاص كيف تنظرون الى
هذه الجهود السعوديه الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
السودان هي بالحقيقه كل يعني اي حاجه يمكن
يعني تؤدي الى استقرار البلاد نحن نؤيده
هي كلها يعني ايجابيه ولكن نتمنى انه كل
هذه المبادرات يعني تصب في بوطره واحده
وتكون في منصه واحده الان هنا نحن الان
لدينا مبادره واداره الخلاصه الوطني
وتواصلنا مع الجانب في الجامعه العربيه
جامعه الدول العربيه وايضا تواصلنا مع
الاتحاد الافريقي والان ايضا هذه المبادره
او الخطوات بين السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولكن نتمنى انه هذه
الجهود الثلاثه الحسيسه يعني نتمنى انه
تكون في منصه واحده يعني للتوحيد
المبادرات
والى يعني تقصير الظل الخطوات
السلبيه الموجوده الان يعني سببها الحرب
والكوارث على رؤوس الشعب السوداني ولكن
الاستاذ عثمان كل هذه المبادرات طبعا
الجهود السعوديه والامريكيه كذلك واضح ان
الطرفين يعني اقصى ما سيقدمانه هو فتح
ممرات انسانيه
عقدهن هشه كما حصل في الايام الماضيه
لماذا لا توجد اي رغبه من الطرفين لتقديم
المزيد برا هو بالحقيقه لانه اولا الطرفين
هم يعني ليس يعني ديدين بعضهم البعض هذه
الدعم السريع هو جزء لا تجزا من القوات
المسلحه وانشئ بقانون عسكري يعني عام 2017
فبالتالي الان هو تمرد على الشرعيه
الرئيسيه في الدوله
وقوات الشعب المسلحيه تمثل
الدوله السودانيه فبالتالي الان اي حسم
يتم وفقا للقوانين العسكريه حتى لو في
محاكمات
لبعض افراد الدعم السريع راح تكون يعني
للقوانين العسكريه وليست للقوانين المدنيه
في المحاكم المدنيه ولكن نحن الان يعني
نرى انه اولا وقف اطلاق النار وسحب
المقاتلين واللجوء الى الى منصه المفاوضات
واطلاق العمليه السياسيه نعم ولكن استاذ
عثمان هناك قد يقول قائل انه في هذه
الحاله الدعم السريع هنا يواجه مصيرا
انتحاريا هو بهذا بهذا الحل هل هناك مخرج
امن بعد 21 يوم من القتال بين طرفين
هو اصلا اي شيء يحصل لابد ان يعود الى
مائده المفاوضات هذه النقطه اللي انت
ذكرتها لابد ان تناقش في معده المفاوضات
ولكن نحن الان نبدا انه الخطوه يعني
الاولى كيفيه يعني يتم يعني ايقاف هذا
الحرب وسحب المقاتلين لانه الان الدعم
السريع هو يستعمل يعني المواطنين كدروع
بشريه الان يضرب
ويقتحم المنازل ويضرب المستشفيات ويضرب
السفارات والبحسات الدبلوماسيه الموجوده
في الخرطوم نعم طيب فيما يتعلق الان
بالوضع انتم كقوى سياسيه هل مازلتم تعولون
على اي مسار سياسي
انتقالي الذي كان بدا فيه قبل اندلاع هذه
الاحداث استاذ عثمان هو لابد ان يتم يعني
فتح مسار سياسي ولكن نحن نرى انه المسار
ان يعود الى مسار
19 هنا 2019 اللي هي منصه التاسيس الاولى
لقوى الحريه والتغيير وايضا لابد ان يتم
اعاده العمل بالوثيقه الدستوريه الاولى
التي توافق عليها الشعبي وتوافقت عليها
القوى السياسيه الاولى نعم طيب ولكن هذه
المواجهه بين الجيش والدعم السريع استاذ
عثمان اربكت المشهد السوداني واعادته الى
يعني اكثر من المربع الاول ربما كما يعتقد
البعض
هل يعني انتم كقوه مدنيه تعتقدون انه ما
يزال هناك هامش للمطالبه بدوله مدنيه لابد
حتى الجيش يعني هو يعني الجهاز زاويه
العامه محترف انه بيقول انا يعني في عده
تصريحات يعني السيد يعني تنسب للسيد
البرهان بيقول انا ملتزم بالعمليه
السياسيه وسوف اسير يعني في يعني يعني في
جدول العمليه السياسيه حتى النهايه
فالان الوضع الحاصل نحن يعني نريد الان
ايقاف الحرب وسحب المقاتلين وثم بعد اطلاق
العمليه السياسيه
اشكركم شكرا جزيلا استاذ عثمان انتم رئيس
تحالف قوى الخلاصه الوطني السوداني
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات